Can you go out in the streets in New
York and ask that question?
Younger people were pretty fired up.
I,
uh,
I've never been a,
you know,
bushes,
the devil Kinda guy.
I really take offense at sort of the,
the uh,
uh,
comparisons to totalitarianism.
Somebody sent me an email recently and
compared,
uh,
you know,
this administration,
what it was doing to what had been done
in sort of communist the early years of
the communist Soviet Union.
And there was some comparison and I just
wrote,
I write this people,
I consider it my personal responsibility
as a journalist to write people back
even when they're praising me and being
nice and I don't need the fight,
you know,
to write people back and say,
look,
I have to reject this premise.
This is not good.
Like there's nothing about this country
today.
That was true in the early years of the
communist Soviet Union.
Like you,
you say what you want about George W dot
Bush.
He is not stolen.
So let's not,
you know,
be ridiculous.
Having said that,
I think his legacy will be treated
harshly.
I'm not alone.
Of course,
that's the majority of your book
reminded my reason if for no other
reason,
if you took all the policies out of it,
so you just took a rock out of it.
Let's say,
let's say a rock is not the defining a
thing of his in a defining issue.
We think it is now,
or let's say it's not foreign policy,
if for no other reason than he entered
office at a time of,
of incredible,
paralyzing division in the country that
he promised to amend it and that he made
it infinitely worse.
Uh,
that is his greatest disservice as a
president.
That alone makes him a failed president,
if nothing else did in my mind,
uh,
because he,
he retarded the dialogue and the
conversation in a country that
desperately needed to advance it.
And for that,
I think history will judge them harshly
and whatever else,
uh,
you know,
whatever else comes out of his
presidency will be judged beyond this.